l'unicef l'organisation des nations
unies s'occupant de la santé dans le
monde présente aujourd'hui un rapport
sur la condition des enfants et les
moyens de l'améliorer au cours de
l'année 85 années mondiale de l'enfance
c'est vrai que souvent les efforts
internationaux ne sont pas suffisants ou
plutôt décevant mais tout de même des
progrès énormes sont réalisés par
exemple notre spécialiste martina
regnault qui rentre de colombie nous
montre comment un plan de vaccination au
niveau d'un pays tout entier peut sauver
des milliers de vie tous les moyens sont
bons quand il s'agit de protéger leur
santé les enfants avec l'aide de
l'unicef
la colombie a tenté une première
mondiale dans ce domaine et la ruse à
grand renfort de fête foraine deux
chants de danses de marionnettes affiche
de banderoles on a motivé dans les
villes les campagnes les petits comme
les grands pour leur expliquer les
avantages de la vaccination contre les
cinq maladies les plus mortelles du
monde avec le concours de tous les
journaux de la radio de la télévision
avec des dessins animés
il fut décidé de vacciner tous les
enfants de colombie en trois journées
nationales et aussi d'expliquer à la
population entière
le calendrier des vaccinations et la
nécessité d'injection de rappel au total
huit cent mille petits colombiens ont
été vaccinées en trois jours dans
l'ensemble du pays
dans les villes comme dans les jungles
et plus reculées plus de dix mille
centres de vaccination ont été installés
et plus de 120 mille volontaires
mobilisé l'armée la police l'église la
croix-rouge d'administration tout le
monde a coopéré y compris par
hélicoptère
pour lutter contre la diphtérie le
tétanos la polio la coqueluche et la
rougeole phénomène incroyable quasi
miraculeux 75 % des enfants de moins
d'un an ont été entièrement vaccinées
rappelle compris c'est une réussite sans
précédent en santé publique qui pourrait
bien être reprise dans d'autres pays en
voie de développement